the minister of code
says that ministers who knowingly
mislead parliament will be expected to
offer their resignation
does the prime minister believe that
applies to him
prime minister mr speaker of course but
let me tell the house that i think he's
inviting a question about an
investigation which is uh you know mr
speaker i can't uh comment and uh uh
which i which he is a as a lawyer mr
speaker will know that i that i can't
comment on and what i am focused on is
delivering the fastest recovery of any
european uh
of any uh european economy uh from covid
uh the uh the fastest booster rollout
400 000 more people on the payrolls now
than there were before the pandemic
began and we're launching a policy
tomorrow mr speaker uh he talks about he
talks about people being out of work uh
in my case uh that's you and i
understand why he wants it we're
launching a plan tomorrow mr speaker to
get half a million people off welfare
into work it's a fantastic idea i hope
he supports it
i think the prime minister said yes he
agrees the code does apply to him
and therefore if he misled parliament he
must resign
on the 1st of december the prime
minister told this house in relation to
parties during lockdown all guidance was
followed completely in number 10 from
that dispatch box
on the 8th of december looks quizzical
he said it on the 8th of december the
prime minister told this house i have
been repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged there was no party
so since he acknowledges the minister of
code applies to him will he now resign
no mr speaker
but you know
ccr since he asked
since he asks about about covid
restrictions uh let me just remind the
house and indeed remind uh the country
that he has been relentlessly
opportunistic
he has he has he has flip flop he has
flip flop from one side uh to the other
uh he would have kept us he would have
kept us in lockdown in the summer mr
speaker he would have taken us back into
lockdown at christmas mr speaker and
it's precisely because we didn't listen
to captain hindsight
that we have the fastest growing economy
in the g7 mr speaker and we have got all
the big calls right
[Applause]
the guy that said in hindsight he now
appreciates it was a party
we've discovered the real captain
hindsight haven't we mr speaker
let me spell out this let me spell out
they shout now they're gonna have to go
out and defend some of this nonsense
let me spell out the significance of
yesterday's developments
sue
sue grey
mata to the police having found evidence
of behavior that's potentially a
criminal offence
prime minister if you do not understand
the significance of what happened
yesterday then i really do despair
because the police
having
[Applause]
prime minister the police having got
that material from sue gray subjected to
a test to decide whether to investigate
and that test was whether it was the
most serious and flagrant type of breach
in the rules
the police spelt out that what they
meant by that that those involved knew
or ought to have known what they were
doing was an offense
and that there was little ambiguity
about the absence of any reasonable food
just the prime minister
just the prime minister
this question will continue and i will
here
i will hear the question unfortunately
you might not believe this but our
constituents are very interested in both
the questions and the answers if some
members do not wish to hear it please
leave quietly
here
mr speaker having got the material from
sue gray the police had to take a
decision as to whether what they had
before them was the most serious and
flagrant types of breach of the rules if
members want to laugh at that
laugh
the police spelt out the police felt out
what they meant
they decided on the material they've
already got that they've already got
that those involved knew or ought to
have known what they were doing was an
offense
and that there was little ambiguity
around the absence of any reasonable
defense
does the prime minister really not
understand the damage his behavior is
doing to our country
[Applause]
mr speaker i hope that the right
honourable gentleman understands
that although the issue that he raises
is important uh there is simply no way
as he knows as a lawyer that i can
comment on uh the investigation that he
is currently is currently taking place
but what i ca but what he also knows he
talks about the most serious issue
he talks about the most serious issue
before uh the public today and before
the world today it's almost as though he
was in ignorance of the fact uh mr
speaker that we have a crisis on the
borders of ukraine
i can tell him i can tell him what is
actually what is going on in the cabinet
room of this country is that the uk
government know mr speaker the uk
government is bringing the west together
so that we have
led by this government and this prime
minister and our foreign secretary and
defense secretary to bring the west
together to have the toughest possible
package of sanctions to deter president
putin from what i think would be a
reckless and a catastrophic invasion
that is what this government is doing
we're getting on with the job and i
think he needs to raise his game frankly
[Applause]
can i just say honestly
can i just say to both sides oh
constitution watching it tensions are
running high and what we need to be able
to do is allow the people out there who
are bothered about their futures to hear
what is said
on both sides so please let's give the
respect our constituents deserve kirsten
mr speaker this was the prime minister
who went into hiding for five days
because of these allegations
talk talk to me about being around for
the allegations
[Applause]
mr speaker
[Music]
can i just say i don't want to do this
but i am determined to make sure our
constituents can hear the next person
that stops me hearing will not be
continuing in this debate
questions mr speaker the prime
minister's continual defenses wait for
the sue grey report
on the 8th of december he told this
house i will place a copy of the report
in the library of the house of commons
his spokesperson has repeatedly stated
that means the full report
not parts of the report not a summary of
the report not an edited copy
so can the prime minister confirm that
he will publish the full sue grey report
as he receives
[Applause]
mr speaker what i can tell him is that
we've got to leave the report to the
independent uh investigators he knows uh
and of course
when i receive it of course i will do
exactly uh what i said but i can i can
tell him that in the meantime i think
what the people of this country want to
hear is what we're doing to what we're
doing to tackle the issues that matter
to all of us
fixing
fixing the cost of living mr speaker
helping people across across the country
by lifting the living wage mr speaker by
helping people with their fuel costs mr
speaker as this government is and by
cutting the tax of people on universal
credit cutting the tax by a thousand
pounds and mr speaker that party
opposite are committed to abolishing
universal credit that's their policy
kirsten
[Music]
[Laughter]
the police say the evidence as
meets the test frankly the public have
made up their minds they know he's not
fit for the job and that's what really
matters here throughout this scandal the
tourists have done immense damage to
public trust when the leader of the
scottish conservative said the prime
minister should resign the leader of the
house called him a lightweight
con english conservatives publicly
undermining the union by trading
scotland with utter disdain
how much damage are the prime minister's
cabinet prepared to do to save his skin
yes
uh well mr speaker i think that he was
uh offering a yet more general criticism
of uh what's been going on in downing
street let me just remind the house
what's been going on in in dining street
uh we've been prioritizing the covid
backlogs uh mr speaker investing
investing massively in nine million more
scans so that people get the treatment
that they need and that they've been
waiting for and making sure that we have
forty four thousand more people in our
reddit yes for he says it's rubbish they
didn't vote for it mr speaker they don't
support it forty four thousand
forty four thousand more people in our
nhs now than there were uh in 2020
and and we're fixing social care mr
speaker which which governments have
neglected for decades and labor did
absolutely they have no plan at all to
fix the nhs or to fix social care vote
labor wait longer
the reality is that we now have the
shameful spectacle of a prime minister
of the united kingdom being subject to a
police investigation
unable to leave the country
incapable of doing the right thing
and every day his cabinet failed to
speak out they become more and more
complicit
and what's utterly damning
despite the huff and puff is that this
is all happening when petrol prices the
weekly shop and energy bills are going
through the roof three months ago
labour suggested cutting v80 from energy
bills still the government has failed to
act
instead of getting on with their jobs
they're wheeled out to save his
whatever he says in his statement later
today or tomorrow won't change the facts
isn't this a prime minister and a
government that have shown nothing but
contempt for the decency honesty and
respect that define this country
no mr speaker uh we love this country
and we're doing everything in our power
to help this country
and and of course of course he wants me
out of the way mr speaker of course that
of course he wants me out of the way uh
he does and i can't and many people of
course of course i i don't deny
for all sorts of reasons many people may
want me out of the way but i tell you
the reason he wants me out of the way is
because he knows that this government
can be trusted to deliver
and we did
and we delivered on brexit mr speaker he
voted 48 times he voted 48 times to take
this country back into the european
union we delivered we do he can't
protect we vote we deliver the fastest
vaccine rollout in europe uh mr speaker
and we will deliver on our plan to unite
and level up across the whole of the uk
prime down 10 mr speaker job vacancies
at a record high colossal investment in
yes mr speaker we're delivering and they
have no plan three times as much tech
investment as france in this country
twice as much as germany we have a
vision for this country as the most as
the most prosperous and successful
economy in europe because we are going
to unite and level up the problem with
the labour party today mr speaker is
that he's a lawyer
not a leader
[Applause]
we've taken the tough decisions
[Applause]
i can't see what the prime minister's
got to say no
i would have thought i would have
thought is the prime minister
of this side of the house i'm surprised
that this side of the hostels want to
listen to it because i do prime minister
well mr speaker i only wanted to add the
point that we've taken the tough
decisions we've got the big calls right
and were and in particular i am getting
on with the job